[Applause]
okay we're in overtime
[Applause]
uh
senator klobuchar some of the biggest
threats we see for on our democracy are
at the state houses yet we have fewer
and fewer journalists covering state
legislatures and city halls
i assume that's true i guess so you have
legislation that would strengthen local
journalism oh what exactly would this
legislation do
well i think this is what we've been
talking about today is that if you don't
have coverage of things democracy dies
right and what's been going on around
the country is more and more local
newspapers local radio tv have been
folding and a lot of this has to do with
the fact that they generate content and
facebook and google put it up and they
get like a little snippet of it and they
don't have to pay them for anything
and what this bill does and it's
bipartisan we're just introducing it
it basically says you've got to let
these smaller venues these newspapers tv
stations be able to join together and
get an exemption from the law so they
can join together to negotiate better
rates with google and facebook because
otherwise they're just going to die on
the buy
because their revenues google's went up
66 million dollars to a billion dollars
in three months 66 billion dollars in
three months from ad revenue and
meanwhile more and more newspapers
thousands of them are shutting down so
this evens a playing field australia
just did it they're able to get better
rates for their news content and you're
able to pay the journalists that are
doing the investigation and writing the
stories and just plugging it in to the
big tech companies yeah
it is a shame about local papers
i mean i remember when i was a kid the
bergen evening record
was on our doorstep and there was like
an afternoon edition yeah well they
covered the football games they cover
it's also things that bring the
community together
um and they know when the the flood is
coming they tell them what you're
supposed to do and if there's no local
media and it's all nationalized you're
going to lose that really important part
of our democracy okay
um
rob you recently uh mentioned that you
believe archie bunker would have
supported trump but would have condemned
the insurrectionist how do you think
he'd vote in the next presidential
election i i think he's one of those
people that would have had enough of
trump i know his point yeah
yeah
and and you see a lot of uh republicans
peeling off now and and i think that's
that's a good thing because this this is
not a uh uh uh
this is not a political party anymore
i i don't know what this is this is some
you know
the cult you know whatever but it's it's
you know they you know this i believe
it's there's a christian nationalist
movement that's very frightening
and and i've actually i'm finishing up a
documentary on it called uh christian
nationalism the danger it's called god
and country the danger of christian
nationalism and it's and it's basically
they take somebody like donald trump who
doesn't espouse anything that they
believe in and they
elevate him to god-like status and that
whatever he does is okay so
um well i there i mean
first of all
trump was losing steam before the raid
at mar-a-lago yeah i mean i i i it's the
election
i mean he lost by seven million votes
yeah but
he was not as unpopular right after the
election as he was right before the
mar-a-lago rate he was steadily going
down desantis was stealing his thunder
and it looked like desantis was going to
get the nomination or at least had a
fighting chance then the raid came and
look i don't agree with you about archie
booker there are republicans peeling
away i don't think he would have been
one of them i don't think he was he was
not a bright guy and he was just it was
all based on loyalty and personality and
also that he was he was an angry guy
yeah he was not happy with his life and
that's the that's what fuels
you might be right normally or just
turned a hundred so let's ask him what
he thinks
hard time thinking archie bunker would
turn on
somebody who who just loved to stick his
finger in the eye of the elite that's
what archie bunker did you think that
dick cheney's daughter would turn on
trump and she did i mean liz janey i'm
saying there are a number of republicans
especially those that came forward and
testified at the january 6 commission
yes maybe they wouldn't have even done
it right after the election but over
time it just the guilt and what they're
seeing happening to our democracy and
he's still out there well yeah people
can change
well i don't know if they
i don't think the republicans change i
people within the republican party there
are people abandoning their party and
they are voting in places like kansas
but those and independents have a strong
voice here those republicans i don't
give up on some of these people i know
happened 30 but not the rest seven seven
republicans in the in the senate voted
to convict trump over january 6 without
all the information that we have now
that's seven republicans i mean if they
have ten more he you know i mean there
are a lot of republicans that are not
are fed up with i agree i can guarantee
you mitch mcconnell is not thrilled
right now with having to support trump
he's not well i don't know if he's going
to anymore because trump came out today
attacking
mitch mcconnell
he he
in a really
i know it's hard to believe
mean-spirited way
[Applause]
it's rumored that liz cheney here we go
we'll run in the 2024 presidential
election oh we could have two women
running
[Applause]
do
um
do you think her running will end up
hurting biden and helping trump
could be the opposite
i don't do hypotheticals but i what i've
seen here is that one joe biden has
racked up a number of incredible
accomplishments in the last year we know
them semiconductors burn pits for our
veterans you name it uh sweden and
finland in the nato treaty um and then
to finland were you at that party with
was i at that party
i wish i was that i wish i wish i was
that top party
no but i mean you didn't
did you think it was terribly
inappropriate you know what i thought
was interesting the same week uh that
she was criticized and uh for that the
australian prime minister was at a
private concert chugged a beer and
everyone thought it was the coolest
thing in the world when the video came
out um so i do think that there is
double standards and if it wasn't if
there wasn't a double standard we could
play a game called name your favorite
woman president
well that's true i mean
definitely
i mean there's no doubt about that up
until the 21st century the the you know
it was probably was not really in the
cards things have changed a lot in the
last generation about gender sex race
i don't think that's the case anymore i
don't think someone is not going to
become president anymore simply because
they're a woman that could be that's
because that's true but they still have
uh a bigger uphill uh climb than a man
they still do
i don't know if that's the case i mean
i've talked to many republicans who did
not like hillary and i said look me in
the eye and tell me what and they will
they could be lying but they're like if
not because she was a woman it's because
she was that woman they really don't
like hillary clinton now i don't agree
but i sometimes people just don't like
you in politics and there are things
that obviously hillary clinton did that
make people not like her but in general
she i think would have certainly would
have been
she would have been the most most
qualified woman ever to become president
of the united states qualified doesn't
make you necessarily a good president
well i mean you're qualified and also
knowing how government works much like
joe biden he knows how it works and he
gets things done i think of those four
years if hillary had been president
versus what we had oh my god
you can't make it i i just said that she
would have been but
this is a different issue i'm arguing
here i'm saying just being quiet you
know who was super qualified buchanan
okay
you can james buchanan
you were there 18 no i i no was i there
you know that's what millennials say i
wasn't there it didn't exist it's not
what somebody your age says no there's a
thing called a history book
yeah i think
i i think
the point is over time it's been getting
better but for so long people are
willing to vote for women for the
legislature things like that but they
were afraid of having them run things
right so we had so few women governors
we're starting to have more we still
have a lot less than we should uh we
have including democratic woman laura
kelly is the governor by the way of
kansas
we had so few women in positions of
power mayors police chiefs things like
that that's changing poll after poll
showed that that was the step that the
voters had to take and i would agree
with you i think there's been a major
shift yeah millard fillmore very quietly
terrible all right thank you
terrible president but very qualified
all right thank you folks
you